there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock alright here we are we're
back again and it's time for another
episode of 13 o'clock this is episode
144 yeah goddamn I can't believe we got
that many episodes done this one Jill
DeRay yeah it's kind of like a French
countess Bathory but it's a man well as
far as we know far as we know yeah this
is another interesting case this is very
much like the Elizabeth báthory case in
the sense that it's kind of a thing
where he has this reputation I'm I don't
think he's as well known as Countess
báthory but it's a similar kind of thing
where he supposedly like this big serial
killer that kills all these people and
he's a noble and yeah you know later on
there's some question about how many
people he killed and all they were
saying that he liked decapitated
thousands of children and put their
heads on spikes and had the guests look
at him and tell him which and decide
which one's the prettiest and all but I
didn't know anything about this case and
I didn't really research the change at
all the work on this I just asked a few
questions why we were out on a walk and
I've come to a conclusion about it but
wool well we'll talk about the case
first they're not gonna know not gonna
spoil it for people who don't know yeah
I actually ended up first an interesting
case it is yeah like I first heard about
this guy I was reading a short story and
I think one of the characters in the
short story had a book about him and
they were talking about like all the
tortures and murder and stuff like that
and I'm like who is that so I looked it
up cuz I was just a little kid at the
time but I feel like like I said he he's
very similar kind of figure to Elizabeth
bass their bathroom in a little bit like
Vlad the Impaler but I feel like he's
not as well known although it should be
said and I'm not sure how accurate this
is but there are some sources that say
that Zelda Rae was actually the in
operation for the story of Bluebird
Bluebeard at least in some of its
iterations yeah this guy didn't really
have his his gimmick was a little bit
differently you know it was a little bit
different
I mean Vlad the Impaler you knew what
you were dealing with when you were
doing with Vlad I mean he was bad he was
bad dude you know he's a warrior yeah
and then guess you could say Bathory
hurt her and in her local area you know
she people considered her to be kind of
spooky you know thought maybe she had
something to do with always missing kids
[Music]
exactly this guy's
Jilla right kind of had up he had a
different vibe to him you know he was
one of these fabulous [ __ ] done
about but also a military badass yeah so
and then later dressed well had a lot of
money handled you know was real popular
with the peasants seen on a man and
everybody liked him so he had a
different image yeah you know until
these allegations came up yeah you know
we'll get into it yeah rich this dude
was rich yeah yeah and I'm pretty sure
that somebody actually recommended this
I think I would have got around to it
eventually except always thought he was
kind of a fascinating guy but I think
somebody recommended it so we're finally
getting around to it so before we do
that let me just give one little
shout-out we got a very generous PayPal
donation that's right one named Robina
she sent us 50 bucks so thank you very
much that is always so awesome when I
open my email in the morning and see
that yeah if you can't get us on PayPal
don't worry you can see you can send it
to us directly through um you can dump
it you can teach us on patreon yeah you
can get us through PayPal yeah you know
you got a link to our paper too to you
it's on yeah it's on the blog and
there's one and it's in the show notes
always too yeah you know some people you
know that you know life is life some
people can't agree to like pay you a
certain amount of month maybe they don't
know what's gonna be happening that
month well yeah I totally get that if
that happens with with us but if you're
one just you know drop us a five but
five or if drop us a ten or madamn this
one she drops us a fifty that's a huge
one yeah that's happening several times
we've kind of I guess we've given
shoutouts to people who
yeah I try to always do that like I
don't think we ever mentioned the amount
but you know on the next show that I
record I always try to like but we get a
lot of 20s and stuff you know but [ __ ]
you know 50 thank you very much yeah
that's it yeah it's a problem like I
said you know anybody that can if you
can get give us anything that's cool if
you can't that's cool you know like I
said you know sometimes especially since
I've freelance and stuff so sometimes I
don't know how much money but I'm at the
end of the month either right you know
pretty much I can only give I give
actually - welcome to the basement show
on YouTube but that's pretty much all I
can yeah that's all I can like safely
I've thought about giving to other ones
that I'm just like well I don't know if
I'm gonna run out of money this month so
yeah
what's funny with like with patreon and
you used to be the patreon if you gave
like a dollar a month patreon got almost
all of it I don't know if it was still
like that at the time you know I mean
like you know the creator ended up
keeping like 25 cents
yeah they free structured some a little
bit probably changed it you know but
we're at the point now you know ii mean
if somebody if you guys just want to
give us a $2 a month or something man go
for it I don't know if we have that
selection on the on the page you don't
actually put industry in enter whatever
you want and you know it's at the point
now you know if you you know if you guys
can help us reach a thousand a month
that'd be great and like I said what i
tried to do it's like everybody that
gives $20 an up a month you know you
know i send a little care packages out
of various things like you know every
quarter but another thing i started
doing is that even if you don't if you
give less than $20 a month then i still
do like a quarterly drawing right so you
might still get some stuff
yeah well i think anybody who is on
patreon doesn't matter how much they
give us they all get to see the show
early right yeah I do early access for
all those patrons that's what you get
for $2 a month's early access yeah and
like I said it's I've been trying I
wanted to like kind of put up you know
other little videos like on patreon like
you know free outtakes and stuff but
that's the thing that we don't really do
it because I don't really take anything
we're so busy especially with the movie
reviews and everything else that we
going on and we're right in the books
the audiobooks and all this other [ __ ]
the freelancing the magazine articles
that she's writing do you just don't
really have a whole lot of time for this
yeah to do extra video stuff they would
try to throw in some of the cat you know
when I'm sober
grab my tablet and try to take a picture
baby could you do inside
yeah cuz she's always been of course I I
like talk [ __ ] I'm wholly sober pretty
much when you said wouldn't shows
Dillman yeah that's true this is kind of
like mostly this is the only time we're
drinkin the audience loves it when I
start getting a pallet kind of you know
loaded didn't start well yeah because
ten Mississippi stories as the show goes
on you know and you get like a drunker
you tend to get like louder and shouting
and you're going off cause you're like
repeating yourself and like going off
it's different yeah since of the shows
that I'm going like man I don't know I
held it together okay but I can see it I
can see that I'm [ __ ] up
yeah all right Kayla man she drinks too
during the show you drink your vodka
yeah but see I mostly have to talk and
read my notes why can't I so I can just
sit there like drinkin right she makes
it have the show's over
yeah that's when I start editing all
right so I think that was pretty much
the only shout out so okay let's start
talking about Gilda ray
yeah we'll just kind of go through his
biography yeah this guy's pretty
well-documented I mean you know he's not
as shadowy it's a Bathory yeah or your
you know Vlad because you know the
documentation from that era from that
time and place it kind of its body but
this is France we're talking about yeah
I mean this is the same era this was
early 1400 yeah of France you know they
it big yeah if there was a center of
civilization record keeping tickle
akhiya and all those other places out in
the Eastern Europe that was the damn bad
Lance back in this time you know I mean
they barely civilized barbarians
flinging poo at one another this has
made a badass though it was Mad Max land
yeah I guess I was
all right so Jill DeRay they think he
was born in 1405 his dad's name was Gil
eval and his mother's name was Marie de
clay all now his parents died he also
had a younger brother
his parents died when he was pretty
young I think he was only eight or nine
years old I think his dad died in like
some kind of horrible gruesome hunting
accident which some sources say that
Jill DeRay saw happen his mom died of
some undisclosed illness so after that
him and his brother went to live with
their maternal grandfather whose name
was Jean de crayon and he was you know
they don't know I don't think they don't
like a huge amount about him but he was
kind of strict and all this other stuff
now she'll DeRay he seems like he had a
fairly normal childhood he seemed like a
real intelligent kid he was actually
really um kind of precocious like he
learned Latin and Greek and stuff like
that he was very young he could he drew
like illuminated manuscripts and all
this other kind of stuff and he seemed
to like value education intellectual
pursuits that type of stuff now one
thing that his grandfather did which was
maybe not as weird at the time but it's
pretty creepy nowadays it's like pretty
much as soon as he got the kid in his
clutches he's starting to like wanted to
marry him off to somebody you know what
I mean for strategic monetary purposes
when I was the college at the time it
was yeah now even though that was the
culture of the time he started real
early I mean Jill DeRay was 12 years old
the first girl that he tried to hook
shield array up with was for her name
was Jean Pannell she was an heiress in
Normandy well her dad must have been
somebody well yeah that's what I mean
there was always a guy whose dad this is
yeah they're trying to join to it
economic empires yeah that's exactly
what was going on right so it just
seemed weird that like but he was 12 and
she was 4 so he was trying to facilitate
that I think he could steal some
contracts yeah get some deals done
exactly in town so that actually didn't
work out the next one that he tried to
do was he was trying to marry him off to
a woman or a girl named Beatrice de
Rohan and she was actually the Duke of
Brittany's niece and that didn't work
out either but then finally in 1420 so I
guess she'll DeRay was only about 15
years old
Oh Brittany that's that's prime real
estate yeah that's you know I meself
chord we're talking about the upper
crust oh yeah yeah this is do you know
this is that's what these are all noble
thing right yeah these aren't just like
these were like in line for the throne
yeah they aren't like little peasants
getting like that
so in 1420 which I assumed so shield
array would have been about 15 years old
he was finally married off to someone
and he ended up being married to a woman
named Catherine de thoux our she was
also of Brittany and she was also an
heiress now when these two married they
became I mean she was heir to one of the
largest empires in France so you know
our largest estates so when her and Jill
DeRay married they became one of the
richest couples in France they had like
either as nice or nicer [ __ ] than the
King had so these are they were very
very powerful and they had [ __ ] tons of
money now in his early years like in his
late teens early 20s
Jill DeRay had a very distinguished
military career at the time obviously
the Hundred Years War was going on
between france and england so life was
not fun at the time it was pretty much I
mean I was watching this one thing and
you don't really think about it because
you know the Hundred Years War even
though they call it that it actually
went on for 116 years but they're like
so entire generations of people grew up
in this you know this in
of never knowing a time when they
weren't at war
they're like so that was pretty much
those battles murders kidnappings it was
just constant it was going on all the
time and several generations of people
grew up in that environment but I must
say during that period it was not war as
we know it no no okay
you're talking about more like glorified
gang fights yeah in colored you know
colored outfits they were losing and
gaining territory but that was you know
noble families getting access to other
people's lands yeah so they could grow
on it you know you're not talking about
war as we know it you know we're not I'm
a global conflict you know it's oh yeah
I mean obviously it was the fourteen
hundred days or anything right right
these are these like I said these are
very these are almost glorified gang
fights really if you're looking by
today's standards maybe a couple
thousand men on each side but I mean
it's still you have to think too this is
the 1,400 so it's like everything is
filthy and gross
yeah disease yeah and then on top of
that yeah you also have like all these
battles going and you're just constantly
a war with another country your body
days standards Europe was a [ __ ]
country well it isn't the thing about it
is that that's one thing that I kind of
find funny about people that complain
about how shitty the world is now and
stuff like that I'm like what do you
want to go back what are you talking
about right yeah it's like you know I
know it sucks and like other maybe other
parts of the world but in the West like
in the US and Europe itself I was like
[ __ ] you we have toilets and running and
food it's like what are you complaining
are the [ __ ] let me see how it was
that's what I mean right we live better
than like super wealthy being moved back
then yeah like they were still pooping
in a bucket in medieval cities were just
now we just do that if you know we feel
like medieval cities were just full of
open sewage that's terrible I mean you
you can read things in history where
this they couldn't clean the streets the
streets were so filthy this and [ __ ] it
and they just built a wooden a new
to the top of it and if you were on the
first floor you're now in an underground
world filled with [ __ ] because I mean
just from a logistical point of view I
mean think about how ever many people
lived in like in a major city like say
London or Paris or whatever every single
one of those people has to take a dump
at least once a day yeah and then the
horses and the horses and other animals
and stuff you know they had other you
know like the farm animals and the rats
rat-infested yeah they're wild cats
running around eating on the rats and
fleas eating on the rats and then look
things on the fleas it was it was nasty
people you're gonna liked it you woulda
liked it and then and then here's
another thing
it tries me crazy that modern people try
to project modern morality on those
people those people were [ __ ] savages
well compared to us understandably so
yeah I mean look how they lived yeah
it's not like they knew any different
right but yeah so they weren't like us
there have been whole books written
about it their sense of humor was
totally different they were a very cruel
and stupid people I mean their idea of a
good times to tie a bunch of cast
together and throw those cats into a
fire literally yeah they didn't have any
concept of no like an animal could could
feel pain or even humans even human it
was not the same way that we do now it
was rare for just rare to find people
that had compassion that didn't really
exist well like I said you know we're
talking about we're not really talk
about the Dark Age right now we're
talking about the Renaissance but even
in the Renaissance they were not fully
developed humans as you would know them
today they just didn't have the early
childhood development and maybe the
nutrition and it may have been genes too
well I think I mean like I said look how
they grew up it's like everything was
diseased and it's like they probably
live like they didn't have very good
nutrition particularly I mean even the
nobles I you know they lived longer or
probably healthier but not like nowadays
yeah you know they didn't have modern
medicine they didn't have decent food
everything was probably crawling with
bacteria they still would have been kind
of dirty and stinky about today's
standards right exactly yeah
so you know I don't I would be lived in
palaces and they pissed behind the
tapestries that's what I mean I would be
very surprised if anybody to be dog [ __ ]
on a couch doesn't if anybody could kind
of transcend yeah that environment and
like kind of be a decent enough person
right so you know but yeah so all right
so what was I doing okay so his military
career blah blah blah now
when shield array was 16 there was
actually this kind of battle between
there was these two factions it was ones
like the the Duke of Brittany and then
someone else was fighting with them and
Duke John the 6th who was part of the
Duchy of Brittany he was kidnapped by
the other side now because jelled array
was fighting on their side he actually
got that dude released like I don't know
if he went in there and like kicked ass
or if he just like negotiated or
whatever so he actually got the Duke
released and the Duke was so grateful
that he gave shield array like a whole
[ __ ] ton of land and property and all
this other stuff so which increased you
know him and his wife's wealth you know
much much larger so so then about five
years later he goes to and he becomes
like part of the court of Charles the
7th and you know he gets all in the
courtly manners and all that other kind
of stuff then he went on to be a
commander in the Royal Army he got like
all kinds of medals and awards for
bravery and all this stuff now very
famously and this is probably where most
people know I mean other than the serial
killer stuff this is probably where most
people know of him was that in 1429 he
hooked up with Joan of Arc now Joan of
Arc obviously you know she was the the
17 year old peasant girl that turned up
at the court of Charles the seventh we
got it we got do something Bobby yeah is
that so some fish that's a fishy story
but well yeah I want to look more into
that you know and yet Joan of Arc and
says you know I had a vision of the
Archangel Michael
you know the Orly I was surrounded by
the English and it looked like the
French army was going to lose but she
kind of came in and she said no God is
on my side I'm I have all these magical
powers I'm invincible
give me an army and I will defeat them
and for whatever reason
accounts differ like they're not really
sure why the King some accounts say that
the king was actually like terrified of
her because she apparently came in and
could like wound herself and like heal
herself or may at least make it look
like she could heal herself um so there
was some [ __ ] like that going on but you
know in whatever case there's so many
weird stories about that girl I've kind
of wondered whether or not maybe if she
was a fictional character it almost
seems like that might have been a story
that was made up after the fact I want
to look more into it later though well I
can't really yeah I haven't looked at
that much into it but it's just she
those stories kind of um kind of sound
like religious stories about people that
haven't you know in a lot there's a lot
of religions in the world that make up
stories about people that have never
existed and there's something bout Jonah
Varga making that some of that story
just sounds awful fishy that sounds all
awful lot like a religious fable well
like I said I don't know I mean as far
as I know she really did exist I don't
know like all the stories that are told
about her I don't know how much of that
is true well you know I was kind of
raised to believe that Jesus existed but
I kind of doubt whether or not that guy
exists in the form that we're given
those stories are all came from other
religions yeah so if there was a Jesus
he no longer survives in the stories
that were given and then if Jesus isn't
this guy out of these stories then what
made him special you know I mean why
would he be remembered well could it be
that it's just stories based around an
old wise man that came back from the
grave you don't I mean so maybe there
was no Jesus I don't really think there
was one yeah
but it could be that well I'm getting
sidetracked on Joan of Arc but I'm kind
of skeptical about Joan of Arc I got to
hear more about that story but go ahead
all right so
like I said so Joan of Arc you know
comes forth and sales like you know I've
given me an army and I will lead it and
I will defeat the the English and Jill
DeRay was all about that he's like yeah
he was like on her side he's like yeah
she can do it I'm gonna help her out so
so he basically becomes Joan of Arc's
right-hand man now they go into battle
against the English and very famously it
took them nine days but they actually
did beat back the English army and after
that just both Joan of Arc and Jill
DeRay became you know kind of nationwide
heroes because they had you know gotten
rid of the English incursion so you know
they became very well loved now so
according to Jill DeRay she existed yeah
and he left them he fought at her side
in the siege of Orleans do any of his
writings exist about her do you think I
mean well there were other writings
around about both of them and her
existence was confirmed well yes far as
you know yes as far as I know okay I
mean I've never heard anybody say living
man at that time allowing a woman to
have that kind of power source a young
one that was obviously crazy if you ask
me well I'm not sure if they saw her as
crazy I think they saw her as like a
holy person yeah I mean the way she must
have come across you know in a very
convincing manner that she really had
had these visions and she's like I you
know the Archangel Michael showed me
this vision and we're gonna win um and
she must have been very good at
convincing them that she had really seen
that and that she would be able to do
it's just really odd it is very
honorable Wow a woman in those days
that's why dawn armor and to go into
battle I mean they didn't even do that
really in the 1700s well I mean that's
why people remember her because it was
so strange yeah you know I mean now like
I said some accounts that I've read said
that the reason that Charles the seventh
gave her an army was because he was
scared to death of her because he really
did think that she was some kind of like
she's like angel incarnate or so like
that he was afraid of pissing God off
I guess it's social state strange that a
rent a random crazy girl would have the
strength to dawn armor from that era and
to actually have the skills to go into
battle and survive it
yeah did she actually fight I don't know
if she led the army that's they said her
and Jill de red let the army
hmm and it took him nine days but they
won we got the bad guy I'm gonna look at
a look into this you know no no warfare
wasn't quite as cocky you know like
think of that warfare is a very
complicated [ __ ] thing when you're
talking about a lot of logistics
involved there's chains of command
involved there's training involved you
know me you can't ya take a random
person today just put him in charge of
an army although you don't know what she
was up to
yeah she showed up at the court she
would have had to have gotten some kind
of training somewhere well yeah maybe
she did maybe her dad trained her maybe
yeah somebody she knew trained her you
know what I mean
it just sounds off and I mean she was 17
a nobody says Oh a 17 year old girl but
like you know well there were boys were
about fighting at that agent matter back
that's what I mean that wasn't that
wouldn't have been seen as a kid back in
those days that most of the infantry she
was 15 14 yes she would have been seen
as an adult like I said Jill DeRay
married when he was 15 it was like a
nobody thought that was weird so it's
like they didn't have a concept of
teenagers they didn't have a concept of
children and teenagers even in the 1800s
yeah not really as soon as you could
talk you're an adult they put you as in
a suit put you to work in a mine yeah
can I have some more bread or on a farm
is the case maybe
yeah as soon as you were old enough to
walk around and like fish it they're
like all right get to work yeah but yeah
so because of Jill de ray and Joan of
Arc's triumph at the siege of war lion
he was actually made marshal of France
so like I said y'all good got all kind
of accolades got all kind of like medals
and all kind of [ __ ] so after that um he
gets you know he gets his own little
which colleges little royal arms and all
this other [ __ ] now later on what
happened two years after the seizure or
Leon
did very famously Joan of Arc was burned
at the stake now why that happened they
think was because she the the French
people that burned her were actually
like burgundians I guess they printed
who were actually spying for the English
so they were kind of traitors like on
the opposite side and they thought that
they didn't like that she had like
whipped the english's ass and so they
took her prisoner and burned her at the
stake in May at 14 31 now by all
accounts Zelda Rae was not there when
she was burned at the stake but after
she died he seems to have you know
nobody said like I'm sure he was bummed
out about it because I think they were
friends but he kind of like became
disillusioned and he didn't really want
to be in the military anymore and at
this point he had so much money I mean
he was old probably I think he was only
in his 20s at this point yeah he was 24
25 something like that he had so much
money that he didn't really have to do
anything he could just like kind of
fiddle fart around and he'd just have
enough money to do whatever he wanted
but in the way the reason that he had so
much money that was what ended up
getting him into trouble so his
grandfather the one who had tried to set
him up you know have got him married off
to all these girls
he died in 1432 now after the
grandfather died apparently Jill DeRay
really kind of went off on a spending
spree he was like buying all these
castles and properties and stuff which
that wasn't that big a deal because it
was still you know oh it's still real
estate that's fine but yeah money
doesn't fan it vanish when you buy
things like but even then like his
family were like whoa bro you know kind
of tone it down a little bit cuz he was
apparently just like spending money all
over the place it's not like they had a
banking system you could probably trust
though yeah but I wasn't invested he's
bright but was probably doing the right
thing for the day and we'll see you see
you're making it go Lorien don't worry
about that now he must have started this
reckless spending before
grandfather died because after his
grandfather died he ended up this really
fancy like sword and breastplate and
stuff that he had which should have gone
to the older air
which would have been chilled aright the
grandfather left it to Zelda razes
younger brother instead like almost as a
kind of like [ __ ] like hey stop
spending so much money type of thing the
younger brother's name was Rene de la
SUSE by the way so like I said the
property was you know people were like
okay well you're spending into kind of a
lot of money and [ __ ] but okay whatever
it's real estate but then Jill DeRay
decided he was going to indulge some
other hobbies that he had now very
famously what he started spending his
money on was he started staging these
huge elaborate theatrical productions
that were like reenactments of his
battles that he had been in like in the
Hundred Years War including the seizure
for Leon or a bunch of other one that
made sense though you know why because
Roman emperors did that kind of stuff I
mean it was on that level good pretty
much yeah they would reenact entire
battles even naval battles in the middle
of college seems they pay for and if
it's about your greatness of what you
did in your army you know back into your
battle it's it would be the equivalent
of making a movie about yourself yeah
that's essentially what he was doing
that's what that's what he's doing um
but you know what that would be smart
because if you're making movies about
yourself and making movies about your
greatness what does that do in the eyes
of the public that makes the people
believe you to be a great man yeah
except that's not how this worked out
[Laughter]
he's trying to do those yeah but like I
said that's not how that worked out
well that might end up getting your ass
in trouble Yeah right
yes so his most famous play that they
know about was actually called the
mystery of the seizure early on it was
comprised of 20,000 lines of verse had
about 500 extras and 140 speaking parts
like the extras were all the soldiers
and stuff
yeah so he they built these big
elaborate sets he commissioned 600
custom-made costumes which were only
used once like for one production of it
and then they would be destroyed and
then they would make them all over again
for the next production another thing
that he would do was that he would offer
as much free food and drink as he wanted
for anybody that came to the production
so of course everyone was gonna come
because they're like free food you can
have as much boot it was like an
all-you-can-eat buffet but you had no
mine no I'm sure it was like this wasn't
taking place in a theater this is gonna
be open air like virtual reality I'm
walking around yeah you walked around on
this battlefield and watched these
armies fight yeah that's probably what
they're talking about that's crazy
that's a good idea [ __ ] spectators
were there like just drinking all the
food what about stealing what they're
talking about you know this is this is
early multimedia technology this is a
movie and in a theme park all happening
and you know it at once it's like going
to Disney that's free yeah
and you get to see this live-action
reenactment of these battles and hear
about what a badass McCann you know Jill
Reyes yeah you know this is all on his
bill I can understand it but it should
be noted that it went had a huge ego
yeah yeah yeah this should be noted that
when he first started doing this he was
already almost bankrupt you know what I
mean so he was just like throwing money
away and his family was like freaking
out another thing that he did was he
wanted to construct his own chapel on
his one in one of his castles maybe his
favorite castle I don't know that's
really funny to me that somebody has a
favorite castle but he did so he built
one called the Chapel of the Holy
Innocents
now he wanted to get a priest for it but
apparently he couldn't get a priest to
come there or his family was like man
don't encourage him like don't go be in
the don't go give mass or whatever at
his [ __ ] water
to handle this yeah so what Jill DeRay
did instead was he commissioned like
priests robes for himself and then he
gave the sermons himself like and I
don't know if other people showed up or
if you shouldn't they're like it an
empty let's go probably like all for his
staff and stuff I would that's cool yeah
okay so this guy he was he was
definitely a very secular sacrilegious
in the day well that's what people were
complaining about spry like [ __ ] I
could read that you know man all I needs
a fancy dress and I can already there
same [ __ ] yeah that's right yeah that's
probably exactly what he did
well I'm like I said the it they did
actually think it was really blasphemous
actually that was another thing that
people were freaking out about not only
he was a larper this is live action role
play yes that's exactly yeah except he
had more money than sense I guess yeah
he should have thought that if you ask
me I think he's cruising for a prison
yeah just by spending all this money
yeah and like I'm votin yourself and
then building you're building your own
churches and then saying [ __ ] I'm gonna
be my own priest
I'm a priest you know what would be my
own Pope he gets probes Pope robe in a
big hat but yeah so like I said even
when he first started doing this [ __ ]
like in 1432 or whenever it was
he was already like rapidly heading
toward broke and he had already started
selling off some of his properties in
order to finance this huge play that he
was doing yeah this is like Michael
Jackson yeah it's kind of like that in
his priests robes and all this other
kind of [ __ ] I can't believe that [ __ ]
what it's a grown-ass man and his
sucking 20s buying Neverland Ranch for
Ferris wheels and [ __ ] trains and
[ __ ] like that and his mansion and he's
gonna have nothing but little kids
little boys come over and he says what
it's about the children
the photographs of all the mill children
he's well where the [ __ ] are the girls
boys yeah yeah you know dude in his 20s
had that kind of power and that kind of
fame it would just look like a damn
strip club and that made like a palace
and a strip club my train would have
strippers on it my train would have
titties on it fuzz of my twenties he had
that much money in power back then all I
could I all I just thought I was [ __ ]
Thomas the Tank Engine except a girl
train with titties on yeah something
like that you know instead of a countess
tacky as [ __ ] in a bit tacky as [ __ ] and
then our big-ass mansion in Kenner boobs
also have pasties with yeah yeah I'd
have a mansion in every room would have
been a [ __ ] nightclub just a
different nightclub in every room I
could be like you want you wouldn't
stage elaborate plays with like super
elaborate Sam's of all your battles and
stuff no yes I saw Neverland Ranch did a
tour of it it's actually quite cool it's
very 80s looking there at 90s look at if
he asked me yeah the woodwork but it was
it was nice yeah but outside was like an
amusement park had trained and trained
yellow and [ __ ] like that and I'm like
one that's pretty cool but you know
you're a grown-ass man what the [ __ ] do
you need that why do you need to
entertain all these little boys with a
[ __ ] train yeah kind of weird
I wouldn't mind like a cool roller
coaster like yeah or Haunted Mansion
like a Haunted Mansion ride I could be
all about that but I don't want [ __ ] for
little kids I don't want it yes all of
us they're no fun right
all right so so he had been spending all
this ridiculous amount of money his
family was flipping the [ __ ] out you
know see this like he's gonna spend the
whole estate there's not gonna be
anything left
so in 1435 a bunch of his family members
get together and they go right to the
Pope who at the time was Pope Eugene the
fourth and the first thing they asked to
do they said can you like you know his
Chapel of the Holy Innocents that he
belts he's like can you like say that's
not a real thing kid so we can like get
him to not like
tear it down or something like that the
Pope wouldn't do it so then the family
said okay will [ __ ] you we're going to
the king instead now the king I guess he
couldn't really like decommission a
church or whatever I'm not really sure
how that works but the king did say okay
well I will make this like royal edict
that says in this area that we are gonna
like proclaim the jeweled array is like
he spends too much money and here he's
not allowed to sell anymore of his
property and they also made it so that
the subjects of Charles the seventh if
you were a subject of Charles 2/7 you
couldn't enter into a contract with
Gilda ray they said they'd block him
yeah and they block his PayPal account
pretty much yeah they basically made it
Anna's ATM card yeah they put a lock
like on his money just like you knock it
off okay it's like we can't have any
more of this for life yeah for life he's
in his twenties and yeah like I said he
was in his mid-20s at this point they
also said that you know that even if the
cat liked the castle's that he had sold
they said okay well the person that's
living in them now like you can't sell
them like you have to stay there
so they this was like affected a lot of
people yeah so I he must have been
spending a [ __ ] ton of money for
everybody to get involved like this well
I have a hard time wondering I have a
hard time wondering it's weird
why did what did they care I got well
it's it was threatened by all the spin
and money and buying [ __ ] evidence yeah
well like a lot of money yeah well like
I said his wife were one of the richest
I mean couples in France like right up
there with the yummy modern analogy I
can think is back in the day you had
Howard Hughes Howard Hughes owned so
much stuff and had so much money they
had whole FBI divisions and Treasury
divisions trying to figure out how much
he actually owned because you know I
mean he had it veiled in a certain way
where companies owned companies and then
their firewalls another company and they
were just paranoid that Howard Hughes
could
possibly do something crazy like
collapse the stock market yeah and he
was mentally and unstable yeah that it
actually that's a good analogy maybe
that's what they were thinking of
situation is that you got this young guy
with all this [ __ ] money and he's got
this imagination and he's too young to
really control himself he might buy and
spend buy and sell the wrong things and
the wrong order and somehow collapse
Frances Treasury or caused some kind of
a economic bottleneck somewhere some and
I think his family members too I mean
probably had some kind of I mean because
families were very closely a
particularly noble family they were
trying to select their own we're trying
to protect their own financial interests
sure so it's like they don't want him
spending this entire estate because
maybe no chunk of a fortune right you
know what I mean so maybe because maybe
they'll get a chunk of it someday and
they don't want that [ __ ] to happen
could have been that too and they'd
abandon their novel members of his
family went in there and said we got us
help us ma'am because he's gonna [ __ ] up
the family fortune and that's a hundred
of us and we're big part of the economy
yeah I think that's probably exactly
what it was and like I said I'd you know
obviously I didn't live in the 1400s I
didn't know the dude personally but
there might have been kind of an aspect
of you know we're gonna do an
intervention because maybe they really
did think he was losing his marvel maybe
yeah because he really was I mean like I
said buying castles for that you know
type of person is not that crazy but
apparently he bought like a whole [ __ ]
ton of them and then he was just
throwing money at these like big lavish
productions he's feeding all these
peasants and stuff and giving them free
booze and food at every single place
make that make sense that was so maybe
they thought he was thought he was
losing his mind going crazy and he was
putting money in jeopardy right so they
thought they needed to intervene yeah
you know what I mean
they asked the King to step in keep this
young boy in check you had a man right
because it might have been the kind of
case where you know what I mean how like
some you know rube out in the [ __ ]
trailer and
Oklahoma somewhere and they miss a lot
or lottery yeah and then they just start
buying and then like five years later
they're all their money is gone and
they're just like a meth addict I've got
twenty million dollars right four years
later he doesn't have a pot to piss in
because he bought there's two things
yeah I bought all the things and then
gave all the things away and financed
all the things and couldn't pay for it
at all vanished I mean I can understand
how that happens because when you're
poor don't have to manage money well
because you don't have any concept of it
yeah I mean I don't when you like to me
like 20 million dollars even though
intellectually I know that that's a
finite amount and it will eventually run
out I don't think some people have that
concept you know what I mean because if
you're poor and you're just like living
paycheck to paycheck and it's like oh I
make $250 a week I mean when you if you
get twenty million dollars it must seem
like that [ __ ] is never gonna run out
you just key and you just keep spending
and spending as betting and then you're
like oh I don't look at it that way I
was raised to be pretty good with money
in a certain way so you buy things that
make money I mean I can understand how
it happens that yeah I can understand
how have I don't think I would do that
because I'm I'm just a very fruity
choice and there's a lot of [ __ ] I don't
need that give me twenty million and I'm
gonna buy a really nice smaller mansion
invested in something you know what I
mean yeah a little fleet of vehicles and
then I can sit on the rest of that I
could probably live off a [ __ ] fine
it hits I could live off of what do you
call it interest the interest off the
rest of that yeah that's what I mean
because it seems like a lot of things
that people want to buy like if they're
like owning a lottery I'll buy this then
the other thing a lot of that [ __ ] I
don't want I don't want a private plane
I don't want a boat I don't want I don't
you know it's like I wouldn't mind
having like a decent sized house but
then I'd have to pay somebody to clean
it cuz I'm not gonna [ __ ] do it yeah
if that doesn't cost anything when you
have that kind of money trail but other
than that I can't really think of a lot
of [ __ ] I want we were talking about the
other day I said even if we had like a
nice little mansion I said you know what
the only cool thing I would want in
there
I wouldn't mind a pool that'd be nice
but um I hate those well like I said if
someone else was taking care of it then
that would be cool I would like to have
a little movie theater yeah but that's
about the only extravagance that I could
come up with the other stuff I don't
really care about it I don't really want
anything like that I wouldn't want a
pool
[ __ ] maybe a jacuzzi but not a pool
yeah okay we can compromise on that
whenever we win the lottery I never
played the hot never gonna win when it
hard you can make that kind of money
alright so writing books yeah I know I
dated a every time you make books you
make more money they just hang out there
in cyberspace making money yeah just you
know live the dream it's just I'm at the
stage now where it's just like well the
technology didn't exist back in the day
now you can get I know now you can do so
I really do appreciate the [ __ ] you
know print-on-demand
analogy in Amazon yeah yeah and all
because seriously audiobooks I always
wanted to be a writer ever since I was
little yeah and you know the whole thing
like in the 70s and 80s she beats
gatekeepers you had to get an agent that
you had to like you know publishing
house publishing house yeah that's like
that it was just and I got a couple
novels published like by small presses
but it's such a pain and you get so many
rejections and it would I couldn't do
the cover art which I hated because it
was not a it was not it was not a
process of natural selection at all it's
a bunch of vampiric gatekeepers that you
got to pass through each one of them
want to wanted to cut and publishing
houses were [ __ ] extremely greedy but
that's all gone now
did it worry about it yeah well like I
said I your books are good you get you
got a family you make money that's I
like that I have essentially final
control over what I want the product
look like and really like I have aspect
of you know I have control over every
single aspect of the production of it I
can design my own cover if I want I can
lay it out the way I want and I can you
know I can do whatever I want with it
which I like the only thing that changes
you can't hit the jackpot like it was
back in the days there's a lot harder
like there's no not gonna need more
Stephen King's yeah where he got like
$400,000 advance for his first novel
right and before that he'd only
published short stories and like titty
magazines yeah and they were you know
they're products of the publishing
houses in the old system that's all gone
JK Rowling yeah I mean there's still
like novelist nowadays that makes [ __ ]
tons of money but it's a very very small
percentage there's some that you know
make workman like money just like they
would if they had a regular job yeah but
they have to write a lot they have to
write like all the time and that's the
level you're at now yeah which you know
I don't mind doing that because I like
doing that but you know yeah yeah so so
I feel like that
that might have been and I'm not saying
that I don't think that his family were
vampires or that they were no obviously
looking out for their own self-interest
but maybe there was something to the
fact that maybe he was kind of Wiggin
out or maybe he had too much money for
being like 25 years old and he was just
spending money like an idiot and they
thought they would get in there and do
some the French that happen the French
noble scene even all the way up to the
1700s 1800s they lived like rockstars so
if you had a lot of money
you were the [ __ ] okay yeah they live
the life and he was partying if you
asked me partying self-promoting having
fun you know and so you know yeah they
went to his head I'm sure it went to the
his his head yeah yeah you know I'm sure
it did and like I said you know it's
aside from all that like aside from him
having like all this [ __ ] money he
was also a military hero so probably
everywhere he went everybody was like
whoo you're the greatest
it was you know how that happens I'm
like I said you just said it just now
like that's what happens with rock stars
you go around and you just have
everybody telling you all the time how
awesome you are you're gonna start to
believe it after a while yes it's not
true a lot of the stuff about putting on
these big shows and stuff sounds like an
attempt of being kind of like a man of
the people
that's what yeah he's trying and like
hey free food everybody he's trying to
get the people on his side that's what
yes which did work for a while yeah
until later
time to take a break so yeah I was
actually just gonna say okay so like
that whole thing happened you know he
wasn't allowed to enter two contracts
everybody so his credits started going
down the toilet he started going into
debt and all this other kind of [ __ ]
happened and that's where we're gonna
leave it at the break and then when we
get back we're gonna talk about what
chilled array is probably most famous
for all these murders all of that
satanic murder stuff which like I said
we'll get into whether we think it's
really happened or not cuz like I said
this is kind of a countess Bathory
situation yeah and there were some kind
of gray areas with the countess yeah I
tend to think that the countess did do
that so I see her [ __ ] was exaggerated
but I think she probably did user yeah
the yeah I think she did but I don't
think it was and that might there were
just too many complaints about the
countess and there were too many
witnesses of what the investigators
showed up and what they found yeah I'm
gonna give it to them yeah I mean that
might not be the case here so there
might be solutions there but we'll see
so we're gonna take a break right now
and when we come back we're gonna talk
some more about the quote-unquote real
Bluebeard Gilda ray the faceless villain
a collection of the eeriest unsolved
murders of the 20th century volume 2
includes cases spanning the years from
1960 through 1979 featuring such
infamous crimes as the triple homicide
at Lake Bodom the family Massacre known
as the good heart murders the serial
killings of the Zodiac Bible John Jack
the stripper and the freeway phantom the
slaughter of dozens of women and girls
along the highway of tears and the Texas
killing fields and the mysterious death
of suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format
yeah
oh you look awful sleepy
[Music]
[Music]
all right we are back talking about Jill
the right-handed into our second hour
everybody loves the second hour show
these to our shows anyway well it's
funny because we never like intended to
make the show twice as long as we start
this hour-long show just that we just
start yapping and you know everybody I
saw this little side [ __ ] that we go
down this way and talk about crazy [ __ ]
yeah
you know most people are like they're on
in their commute or they're doing
housework or they're you know
commuting to work in the morning you
know just there's no way you know I've
been I'm drinking cold up in bed I do
the same thing you know yeah I I listen
to other people's content and other
people listen to our content I know the
world there's like a cycle like
capitalism one buying from the other
infinite money trading alright so now
that we've gone kind of into the
background of Zelda right we're gonna
get to the good stuff which is yes the
stuff that he's kind of best known for
like the satanic murder and demon demon
summoning and child murdered type stuff
so here we go now Zelda Rae in some
circles is considered one of the very
earliest serial killers by some
estimations he is said to have killed
over a hundred children now there is a
lot of controversy around that number
and some people are of the opinion that
he didn't really kill anybody and this
[ __ ] was all made up later on for
various reasons well I asked you in the
back when we first started planning for
this show you know I asked you a few
questions about this and you and you
answered the questions that I right away
went yeah no you know but yeah you know
cuz
for a crime to have been committed there
has to be evidence there has to be
certain kinds of testimony and it
doesn't look like it's there but why
don't you go ahead and start from the
beginning how does this part of the
story start what happened huh why did
this guy get accused okay of this now as
I said I've run a bunch of different
sources this I read the Wikipedia
article report Annika were like watched
a whole bunch of documentaries about it
now no source seems to agree on where
these stories about this began a lot of
the information that we have about Gilda
ray as far as I can determine came from
testimony at his trial okay now I have
heard that there were rumors about
children disappearing around his castle
like before he was arrested but I'm not
sure who started those for her if it was
like family members of his or if it was
people that didn't like him or something
like that
so the testimony available yeah okay
where is this somewhere in France in a
written form yeah okay and actually I
think there's a book I think the woman's
name is gieux be your last name I can't
wear what her first name is but I think
she wrote a biography of him and she
actually went through and translated a
lot of the trial transcripts from I
think they were originally in Latin
Latin or French and or French and she
translated them into English and she
went back to a lot of the source
material and so a lot of that is in
there
I haven't read the book but I kind of
went through a couple summaries of it so
yeah so like I said no one is quite sure
where the rumors began but so is story
goes in 1438 apparently what Hilda ray
did was because he was getting worried
about being broke dick because everyone
had taken all his money away or he had
spent all of it and then they wouldn't
let him have any more so he allegedly
asked around because he wanted to
contact an alchemist that would
presumably
helped him make some gold now some
people might call [ __ ] on this and
that alchemy they didn't believe in that
in the 1500 they believe in that almost
into the eight they absolutely did all
right
[ __ ] yes there they believe that way
into the seventeen hundreds I mean Oh
what's his name the guy who invented
physics what's his name again [ __ ]
the greatest one of the greatest
scientific minds of all time Isaac
Newton was an alchemist he was yeah you
did you know that yes he was a [ __ ]
alchemist he bullied I brought a couple
of biographies he believed in alchemy I
know and so yeah that's really that's
how he got the job protecting the
Treasury in England is cuz he said that
he could catch alchemists because he
believed in it and that yeah he believed
alchemists were out there trying to make
gold which might well they just saw it
as like it was they didn't see it as
like ooh it's magic was not a super
science it was like chemistry right it
was chemistry but they were talking
about chemistry that's what they were
talking about it was even though
chemistry involves spirits too it was
like I said there was it is no the gray
area coming to them it seemed like a
science mission so Christians believed
in spirits and they believed in science
so you know I mean you must must be a
spiritual element to chemistry that's
yeah it wasn't like as weird as crazy as
you think yeah it doesn't seem his word
so he allegedly like Cott wanted to
contact an alchemist so he could make
some gold and get all his like wealth
back so he could apparently keep
spending all the money on plays and
castles and whatever else fast cars
loose women
you know so he guys he finds this
Italian dude named Pilate and apparently
the guy has you know written some books
about alchemy and is like really into
the [ __ ] so they kind of get together
and start trying to make some gold so
apparently they try the ritual three
times
and it doesn't work shockingly so
Jill DeRay apparently gets kind of
pissed off about this and he's like with
[ __ ] man I thought you were an alchemist
and you could make me some gold and then
pray Lottie allegedly says oh well I
guess it's not gonna work because we
need a human sacrifice
we basically need to summon a demon most
of the sources say the demon they
summoned was named Baron or Beryl if you
want to be French about it by wrong yeah
um to actually who I guess was gonna
bring them the gold yeah so they had to
do a human sacrifice
so allegedly the first one that they did
they had to put like pieces of a kid or
a baby like in like a glass vial and
like give it to the demon and I think it
was like I think it was eyeballs heart
and one other thing it was either ears
or hands or finger I don't remember with
this but this is actually going beyond
alchemy this is getting into witchcraft
well yes how can be really when you
looked alchemy was not witchcraft yeah
most alchemists actually who were really
trying to do it we're looking for purity
of soul and spirit and they were trying
to find the Philosopher's Stone which
was could only be found within the self
you know I mean even though alchemy was
illegal alchemy was not evil okay the
reason why alchemy was so evil illegal
is because they didn't want people
making gold if you could make gold then
you could undermine the coffers and the
treasures that the Treasury of kingdoms
didn't want that it wasn't because it
was evil but now you got guys talking
about we're gonna sacrifice babies yeah
like that sounds like witch trying to
shaded over into like oh I'll make you
some money into hey let's kill a baby
right I mean you know purportedly this
is this is what like I said I think all
of the stuff that we know about him
comes from trial transcripts trial
transcripts and like witness testimony
and stuff like that so how true is any
of it I'm not really sure but this is
how the story goes I'm just saying this
is how the story
yeah how it really happened I'm already
calling [ __ ] but go ahead yeah I'm
gonna call [ __ ] because if you hire
an alchemist he's not gonna [ __ ] have
you sacrifice babies to make gold
yeah no Alchemist actually I've ever
read about yeah that's that this is
witchcraft we're talking about but go
ahead good I mean it's a possibility
yeah you know but now as I said there
had been rumors circulating who started
them I don't know but there had been
rumors circulating that there had been
kids that had gone missing around you
know much like in the case of Countess
báthory there had been kids that have
gone missing like around his castle
we're never seen again blah-dee-blah
now you know this was the 1400s and as
we said before people didn't really have
a concept of like childhood per se so
it's like as soon as you had a kid that
was like of age they're just like hey
take this kid and make him a page or
make him so it wasn't like weird to send
your kid off to like live with some dude
somewhere you were supposed to send your
kids yeah basically what you have in
their hand was source and income right
so it wouldn't have been seen as strange
but apparently there were rumors
circulating that there that kids would
go in there like he would offer them
jobs and they would go missing like I
said these were rumors I don't know who
started them and I don't know how
accurate they were but because they kind
of reached a fever pitch Zelda Rae did
eventually get arrested along with
several of his you know servants and you
know people who worked in his house now
at the trial guild array or shield array
rather did give a very detailed
confession now I don't believe that they
actually tortured him but they did
threaten to torture him and I believe
they also threatened to excommunicate
him if he didn't confess to all the [ __ ]
that he did well [ __ ] back in those days
that was enough right because they knew
what torture would be so that's why I
kind of I mean and pretty much anything
anybody says under torture or threat of
torture that's you just can't it might
be true it might not be true I don't I
don't think there's not iron Stu
somebody you screw down on somebody's
thumbs and you do all that [ __ ] that
they did to the people long enough you
get them to say anything and like I said
this is we did a show on the witch
trials obviously those women that were
hanged or burned in Europe I don't think
they did any of the [ __ ] that they were
accused of doing but obviously if you
like put thumb screws on people or put
people in iron maidens they'll just be
like yeah what do you want me to say
just write the [ __ ] down and I'll sign
it just stop doing that torture is
ineffective when it comes to trying to
get somebody to confess to [ __ ]
spiritual crimes and all kinds of [ __ ]
that can't be verified anyway not to say
that torture doesn't work torture works
but it has to be you have to be asking
people questions that could be verified
that's what I mean it's like if your
time I like you you know
you can capture an enemy soldier and
beat on him and he can tell you
something and if you can verify it that
yeah it worked but you can't torture a
person and get them to [ __ ] confess
to [ __ ] worshipping the devil and
doing also the kind of [ __ ] and be able
to verify go yeah that [ __ ] worked yeah
I totally did you kiss the ass of the
devil he did that yeah no the calls
confession didn't work it's all right
thank you I said what am I didn't know I
got a little table here I'd [ __ ] put
my and the table is like this is the
table cool it's not the most stable no
it's like six inches by six inches and
it's just made of like ball so it's like
so it's like every time a booth so every
time he does this show and get
straightened he's like start scaling
around I'm always afraid he's gonna
knock it back bamboo is the original
Japanese plastic that's a [ __ ] wonder
material did you know that that's only
black because I painted it yeah but I'm
just saying it's black bamboo disbanded
man I'm just saying it's black cuz I
painted it it wasn't black originally
I'm telling you
bamboo was Japanese original plastic you
can actually make a gun
bamboo just a spoken-- I know just a
second Captain Kirk we shot the Gorn
with eye I can't ask cat I think Kirk
because he's a fictional character but
yeah so okay now according to after they
arrested Zelda and all his quote unquote
henchmen um he pretty much they said
okay well we're gonna torture you fit on
don't tell us stuff and he's like okay
we'll sit right down I'm gonna tell you
so apparently he gave like a really
detailed confession now according to his
confession the first child murders
started in four in 1432 and he said that
he'd done the first ones at this one
Castle that he had two and then he moved
to this other Castle now he said at this
one particular location that he had
killed or had he had either killed him
himself or he had told like his servants
to kill them but that he had sodomized
them first now there was this one
particular case and I'm not sure what
year this is from but there was a case
of a little boy he was 12 years old and
his first name were his last name rather
was Judah now he was a furriers
apprentice now according to witness
testimony this boy was approached or his
parents were approached by not by Zelda
Rae but by Zelda raised cousin or two of
his cousins who came and said hey can we
borrow this kid for a minute because we
want him to like run an errand
okay you guys think we brother's kid who
got a sodomizing well they're not gonna
say that out let me just borrow this kid
borrow that I get cuz we will be
blinging back right [ __ ] back in those
days that might have flown I don't know
it probably would have sadly enough we
want to bugger this kid we'll bring him
back in a minute okay go ahead I'll give
you twenty dollars twenty shilling
I wish point the parents would be like
okay yeah that's they yeah they probably
would have
so they wanted to bar him to like run an
errand like to like send a message to
somebody or something like that he was
like an errand boy now they took him
away and the boy did not come back so
then they go to the two cousins and
they're just like hey what the [ __ ]
where's that kid that we loaned you
and they said um oh I don't know like he
did what we asked him to do and then we
didn't see him again maybe like thieves
took him or something
they sold it to the Arabs right like
he's he's in a Turkish [ __ ] harem now
yeah so that was the excuse they gave
now this particular story was apparently
at the trial they had the the furrier
news
this kid was his you know apprentice and
the furriers wife both gave testimony
and they said yeah we loaned that kid to
these two noble men and then we didn't
see him again they also talked to the
boy's dad and a few other people from
the town that said yeah that totally
happened so I don't know if that really
happened or not but apparently this kid
disappeared after going off with not
chilled array but hit two of his
cousin's two after they had asked if
they could borrow the kid for reasons
that is that it's just like a funny
borrow that kid he's soft and tender we
would like to borrow him here's 30
shillings yeah
French Skilling's was it what was it a
sous I don't know man had a Mississippi
story to tell you oh here we go back in
the day my grandmother went in went into
a dried-out lake bed with a metal
detector one time found piece of melon
did it was I still got it
it was little it was a little five dense
dense skilling from yeah like 16
something roller huh yeah yeah my dad's
got it yeah I don't know what I don't
anything about it you should know it
like what are you usually get somewhere
I get it appraised it's dense skilling
and he was five
but it was like from 16
something-or-other
huh run round the outside Laurel
Mississippi somebody back in 16
something or other like was going to the
I think they were fishing was going to
the 1607 11 to get some cigarettes and a
drop spent fishing along the bank it was
a pretty small Lake you know at the time
that it had water in it
and it dried out in my grandmother's
time it only had a few feet of water in
it a few years later was gone and she
walked out there with a metal detector
that her husband had gotten her at the
time she found it out in the deep part
which would have been about 20 feet deep
but it was within a an arms toss of the
bank so somebody must have been on the
bank fishing and skipped a coin across
the water that's what she thought okay
that makes sense to me I don't know what
a dentist's killing is dense dense k--
said de and ske yes cake I ll I end I
don't think it even had a G maybe it did
have that sound Scandinavian yeah it was
from the 1600s in Mississippi of all
[ __ ] I just wrote an article the
other day about all of these because I
started writing articles for Steve Mehra
and so our entertainment just about
various ancient mysteries and all that
kind of stuff and I was writing one
about all of those weird like it even in
the United States there's some in like
[ __ ] you know Maine and [ __ ] where
they think it's a you know Viking runes
and stuff like carved in rocks and why
not yeah most of them are fakes I think
they pretty much determined that most
were fakes what exactly jump up yeah
like the Vikings they were like I've
been Newfoundland and stuff like that
but they don't think any of them came
down like Oklahoma but there's a bunch
of like stones in Oklahoma that have
[ __ ] sort of looks like runes on it even
though it doesn't really smell actually
it would not surprise me yeah it's crazy
it's not crazy that Vikings made it here
a long long time
yeah they were and it's it would not
surprise me if there were some Viking
stuff yeah it was found but you know I
don't think they made any settlements
we're talking about maybe ten guys that
made it ashore walked around for a while
kill a few Indians Indians killed a few
of them and then they just died out
because Vikings had a bad had a bad
habit of attacking and killing sprayings
yeah yeah to see if you if they were
immortal or not that's what your hold on
just a second I want to see if you can
live through this we're gonna make sure
you're not immoral going over there it's
not you know it's just a mortal spray
like if I ever murder anybody I'm
totally using that as a defense at my
trial I was checking a chicken see he
was immortal right I really thought he
was gonna live through that [ __ ] judge
probably had to know we had to know they
weren't the brightest of people they
were part they were strong but they
didn't think things through you know
they saw things through their cultural
lens well you know stab first ask
questions later all right but I'm sure
there were a lot of oh no I wouldn't
think that they made as far as the West
Coast I mean that's a like most of the
ones that I wrote about were from like
the Midwest like Oklahoma that type of
thing that wasn't like a forest that was
grassland I did see that maybe you could
walk out that far and major live it how
did you hit them Sierra Nevada mountains
I think most of you know cuz most of
them don't look particularly weathered
and most of them are like well most of
them are are kind of a combination of
letters and words from like different
time periods and different alphabets
contrary to what one might be better
thanks today this is not Indian
Territory everybody walked here
they walked here across land bridges you
had white people from Europe walking
across ice sheets ten fifteen thousand
years ago this place was always a big
kind of like racial melting pot of the
entire world they've been coming here
for
20,000 years you know I mean it wasn't
until that damn flat-faced bear went
extinct that a human could live here
when was that about 25,000 years
something like that so people have made
it here by accident for 25 thousand
years and you never really it would not
surprise me if the Chinese came here
some people think they did because they
yeah because they found Chinese boat
anchors off the coast of California that
may be dated back 500 years I've read a
book called 1491 the year China
discovered America or something like
yeah that kind of was arguing for that
hypothesis I'm not taking a stand on
that it might be true it my some people
got these vested arguments I don't
really have I don't have a dog in that
fight if I'm trying to invent it China
discovered it that's fine land doesn't
belong to anybody it's it constantly
being taken by somebody else when we all
just nobody sprouts up out of the ground
you know we're all from Africa and there
and we conquered the rest of the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's how it really goes we all came
from and we've all been taking [ __ ] from
other people give me that give me that
[ __ ] off his land all right so now okay
so some other people that gave testimony
at the trial including like some of Jill
de Rais servants who they also tortured
or threatened with torture should be
noted said how Jill DeRay would would do
with all these kids that he kidnapped
now what they said that he would do he's
like he'd take the kid usually boys but
sometimes it was girls he would take the
kid and he would dress him up super
super nice he would give them like this
really big dinner like all this really
nice lavish food some booze he'd give
him some this kind of drink that was
like a stimulant it was called hippocras
I think that would kind of like you know
get him all revved up or whatever how
about roofies yes of um well no it's not
really it was it was like the coke I
think it was not like okay because it
was like it was a stimulus
it wasn't like really Ruby's asleep so
that people can rape you but um I know
I've been slipped those a couple I was
there though I saved you
no no no this was before I met you
before that yeah if it if you've never
been roofied it's I don't recommend it
but no it was the weirdest experience
ever this was when I was married to my
first husband yeah and I was just like I
had had seriously and I and I drink a
lot I'm not an alcoholic I promise it's
like but I I drink a lot so I have a
black Club people I have a high like
alcohol tolerance I had literally drunk
maybe not even half maybe like a third
of a drink and it was like probably
vodka cranberry something like that so
it was it was like this much alcohol
seriously I drank it and I'm sitting
there listening to the 80s music or
whatever and then all of a sudden I
turned to my friend Nicole and I'm like
babe I don't feel so good and then all
of a sudden I just went home and I just
fell asleep like fell off my stool yeah
they got you yeah and so it was like it
was literally like that yeah somebody
got me I nearly attacked the damn band
called the swans one time with somebody
yeah yeah that was a different thing
that was something else I don't know
what so this was this why I think it was
meant for you
I think but I got it for summer I mean
I've had it had I've had it done to me
several times and I'm sure probably
every woman in the audience has had it
happen at some point if they go to bars
or anything I've had it happen to me I
think three times but the first time it
was I didn't even know what was going on
it was really it was like 11 o'clock and
yeah seriously I took a drink and then I
was I remember distinctly saying I don't
feel so good and then I just fell off my
stool asleep now the next thing I
remember was my then-husband
driving me home I was in the passenger
seat I woke up and I was barfing into my
lap yeah he's frightened at you wouldn't
he he probably thought it was all your
fault prompt well everything's okay he
know so he's 30-something yeah yeah he
figured because I because I have you
weren't there long enough yeah I had
never done that before
and yeah we'd only been there for like
absinthe I have literally drunk half of
my first drink yeah you know what I mean
and for me to just like Falls
little fluoride never done that member
so yeah so yeah alright so getting back
to you like I said we got all distracted
about the yeah stimulants yeah so yeah
so apparently he would give them this
drink that was like a stimulant or
whatever and then you know after this
big meal and after like dressing them up
and fancy clothes and everything then
apparently Jill DeRay would take them up
to this like private chamber like this
private bedroom or whatever and then you
would like spring it on hey guess what
I'm gonna kill you because evidently
allegedly he liked the shock that would
engender like when he actually told the
kid hey you just had the most awesome
day ever like I gave you all this nice
food and nice clothes and everything in
and out yeah so apparently he kind of
got off on that now one of Jill Duran
had what they call a body servant which
what the [ __ ] is that is that somebody
that like washes your ass or yeah maybe
that's what it is in the dress you and
the dresses you and stuff like a groom I
never heard of it called a body servant
though they tell me like a horse groom
somebody that [ __ ] grooms you and cut
your hair and dress you labor was so
cheap back damage they have that you can
have a guy just specifically for that
yeah it's like it's for you this is my
toenail clipper guy and you have one for
like each this is my nose clipper I like
it a nose hair clipper oh yeah maybe
have a bunch of them like specific to
like each part of your body out of it I
don't know how you roll it so I'm just
saying so he had a quote-unquote body
servant named Etienne who they called
him wat - I don't know why but he was
apparently like an accomplice in a lot
of these crimes and I think he actually
got burned at the stake later on for
some of this [ __ ] now he said like I
said take this with a grain of salt
because it was he the torturer threat of
torture that this story came out he said
that what chilled array would do was he
would take the kid
I said almost always boys but there were
some girls too so it wasn't just a just
a boy thing so he would take the kid he
would strip him naked he would hang him
up with like from a hook and then he
would jerk off on the child on the kids
stomach or on his legs or whatever
now if the victim was a boy he would
like fondle his balls and his butt and
everything like that like you do yeah
then you would yeah then he would take
the kid down from the hook this is like
so now yes the hook was in his back
didn't really say I don't know if he put
actually put the hook like I said I
don't know if it was like a Leatherface
situation where he actually like hooked
that up there like meat or if he just
had like if he just had like a like a
rope around his chest or something it
was the kid alive when all this was
going on oh yeah yeah because I think I
would kill a kid yeah well yeah cuz it
would go all the way maybe not I mean
you know depends on the trauma level
true dick the hook was yeah yeah so so
then apparently so after that whole
thing happens like after he's done Cup
and the kids balls or whatever then he
takes I'm just saying this I'm not
making this up you're imagining the [ __ ]
okay go ahead good I'm done imagine okay
cupping his balls he's covered his balls
well they said fondle again I just
assumed
I mean modeling cupping alright look at
this thesaurus okay so what why are you
doing this I don't know I don't think
okay okay so he so he brings the kid
down after all the you know molestation
and then he supposedly tells the kid Oh
everything's gonna be okay I just wanted
to play with you I'm not really gonna do
anything bad and then he or one of his
cousins is like psych and then he either
cuts the kid's head off or dismembers
them or takes a stick and breaks their
neck or something like that he also had
apparently according to the body-servant
quote unquote they had like this
sword that they kind of kept around for
just this purpose like for kid killing
around you know I've got to have one in
every room just in case you never know
when that situations gonna arise so
gotta have a kid killed sword so this is
[ __ ] up so yeah now one thing that I
found on Wikipedia that's apparently a
quote and this I think was a quote from
the trial transcripts from the
body-servant plot to who said and I'm
not sure if I'm reading this correctly
so please correct me if I'm wrong but
according to him
Jill DeRay disdained the victim sexual
organs and took infinitely more pleasure
in bowing himself in this manner than in
using their natural orifice in the
normal manner now from how does that
mean from how I read that it sounded
like it meant that he would cut their
head off and [ __ ] the neck hole it might
no go back again what is this because
what okay now what it says on the
Wikipedia page yeah is that Jill DeRay
sometimes abuse the victims before
wounding them and at other times after
the victim had been slashed in the
throat or decapitated right and then his
manservant says that he disdained the
victims sexual organs like he's like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] right and took infinitely
more pleasure into bowing himself in
this manner
decapitation I guess then in using their
natural orifice in a normal manner which
like I said I took that to me they let
off heads yeah and [ __ ] the neck hole
that's what it sounds like he's talking
about I don't know if that's correct or
not but that sounds like I thought
that's what he was talking about sounds
like he didn't like sexual organs and he
didn't like normal or for all the ball
cupping the way he liked was playing the
heads off that's what it sounded like to
me but you know it's hard to say well de
botching himself de botching him say
he's getting off on it
yes so
I thought that he meant that he was
[ __ ] the neck hole the neck hole the
hole what left when he dicapta I mean I
could be wrong about that but this was
under torture or a threat of torture
editor's that's what it sounded like to
me so take that as you will but that's
kind of what it sounded like he was
talking about now Zelda Rae also said in
his own confession that after the
children were dead he kissed them and
those who had the most handsome limbs
and heads ooh
what a nice elbow you have weird he held
them up to admire them and had their
bodies cruelly cut open and took delight
at the side of their inner organs and
very often when the children were dying
he sat on their stomachs and took
pleasure in seeing them die and laughed
so now that was apparently out of his
own mouth or at least in the trial the
confession from the trial that stands to
this day that's what they wrote down so
maybe they wrote it and they just said
hey we're gonna torture if you don't
sign this and he's just like yeah
whatever and didn't read it I don't know
but that's what was in there so that was
like taking his his confession like
that's what he wrote about what he did
okay is there anything else yeah there's
some others okay what else now they said
that the reason because as far as I can
determine and please correct me if I'm
wrong but I don't think they ever found
any quote-unquote physical evidence I
don't think they ever found any problem
this is the process what I mean I don't
think they ever found any bodies or
anything like that and Zelda Wright did
actually have a lot of friends of his
and like other acquaintances that
apparently came forward and said no he
didn't do any of that [ __ ] I was in his
castle all the time there was none of
this [ __ ] going on but apparently none
of that really made it into the trial
transcript so they didn't want to hear
it or whatever so what the servants and
[ __ ] said they would do is like oh well
after we killed all these kids like
hundreds of them apparently because I
thinks I've seen some estimates like up
to six hundred which seems crazy
hold off question but what were their
complaints of kids missing
do they have warrants I said that before
that they're but like
Sani we're talking about I'm not sure
how accurate that is because they were
like quote-unquote rumors circulating
that kids were going missing but I don't
really know other than that one kid that
they that the cousins asked to
quote-unquote borrow that was cousins
though that wasn't him yeah and the
thing is they could be correct about
that they could have had the kid come
and do a thing and then the kid took off
and got kidnapped by someone else it's
like that's circumstantial right I'm not
saying that didn't happen I'm just
saying that if that was a trial nowadays
that wouldn't fly okay what else is
going on because there's too much of I'm
already kind of like so now the serpent
said that the reason that no bodies were
found was because what they would do is
that after Gilda ray had done all his
whatever like [ __ ] the neck holes or
whatever the [ __ ] he did with the bodies
allegedly that they would either throw
them in the fireplace and burn them and
then they would like put this stuff in
the sass pit or you know they would put
them in the moat or things like that
which seems a little weird because you
would think they would at least find
bone fragments or skulls or something
like that like after all this time and I
as far as I know they have never found
anything like that
yeah burning bodies does not get rid of
the bomb that's what I'm saying it's
like yeah you can say oh I burned it and
it's all gone yeah that's not how that
works and that works I mean even like
crematoriums that has to be like some
really high temperature [ __ ] and even
then they have to crush the bones up at
the end we give you the [ __ ] fragments
right right so it has to be like super
high temperature before the body is
completely obliterated and even then you
still have to like crunch it up right
I'm just saying
so you're really when you look through
history there's been no serial killer
that has effectively gotten rid of a
body through fire they don't do it that
way no and the reason they don't do it
it's too hard it's one it's hard and
it's not as effective as people think it
is it's much if you've been dissolving a
body into an acid it's not effective
doesn't work because teeth and gall
stones are not dissolved by acid protip
the best way to get rid of a body is to
bury it in a place where no one will
find it right and that's
that's clearly the best hard to do in
France in that time yeah I mean you're
talking about an area that even back in
the evenin the $15 was heavily populated
yeah yeah I mean you couldn't have a big
cachet and buried bodies go undetected
for long
especially when you're talking about
hundreds or thousands of bodies no [ __ ]
no know what that does to the soil what
it looks like you know no it doesn't
work doesn't work that way now another
thing that happened to you and this
happened a little bit later was that in
May of 1440 now this actually did happen
as far as I can determine
Jill DeRay got into a sort of property
dispute with a cleric named Jean Lafleur
oh now I'm not sure entirely with the
details of this are but I think Sean the
firaon had either purchased one of his
properties or was squatting there was
staying there or something and Jill
DeRay was not happy about it and he
wanted this particular property back so
he kind of went in there the cleric
wouldn't leave so he decided that he was
going to beat and kidnap him evicted the
[ __ ] out ideas so this was another kind
of mark against him because even though
like most of the kids that were
allegedly kidnapped and murdered and
sodomized and whatnot by Zelda Ray were
peasant children kidnapping and beating
up a cleric was a more serious crime
yeah than kidnapping and murdering
peasant children sadly that would still
get you probably dead doing that too
[ __ ] peasant kids even back about
fifteen hundred's well a lot of things
would get you dead back yet I mean even
like just blasphemy I think yeah it's
you burned at the stake right they would
say that you were a Joan of Arc she
didn't [ __ ] do and I think
homosexuality would was enough to do
that so yeah because I think that was
what they would say they would say you
killed these peasant kids and you raped
them that means that you're a sodomite
and you're an evil Satanist you got to
die
yes that's what they would say and that
was definitely one of so so the fact
that this [ __ ] happened with the cleric
whether or not it
not related to like the kid murders or
anything like that you know the alleged
converters but that was kind of another
mark against him so when he was actually
arrested like I said it was him and two
of his servants were arrested in
September of 1440 and they were actually
charged with murder sodomy and heresy or
witchcraft performing witchcraft or
whatever because the whole demon
somebody why not so as I said you know
this is like from the trial testimony
it appears that Gilda ray may have
killed between 80 and 200 children some
estimates as high as 600 as I said I'm
not sure how accurate this is because
it's pretty much based entirely on
witness testimony that came from you
know either torture or threat of torture
now so they hear all these people
talking about it as far as I know like I
said some they did have some testimony
from like peasants in the area that said
yeah like yeah my kid went missing and
it seemed like weird because it was kind
of around the castle or whatever but you
know again that's circumstantial because
there was so much other [ __ ] going on
there were thieves on the road there
were people as you know you let your kid
like run around loose and you weren't
really supervising them it's like who
knows what could have happened or they
just run away or they could have just
run away so that's not so that's it
I don't know well I'm not saying that
the [ __ ] didn't happen I'm just saying
that it that the circumstances are it's
it's all circumstantial evidence I'm
just saying they didn't find any
physical evidence so now after they
heard after the court heard the
testimony of Gilda raised two servants
who were named parts ayo like I said and
Henry a now they were both condemned to
death they were found guilty contempt
condemned to death and they were
actually both I think they were hanged
first and then burned and they were just
burned entirely done nothing in their
ashes were scattered
now Zelda Ray was also found
LT murder sodomy witchcraft whatever and
he was also given a death sentence now
from what I've heard normally what they
would do is they would hang you and then
they would burn your body but they
wouldn't bury you like in hallowed
ground or whatever because you did all
this horrible [ __ ] Christian burial but
he did shoulder I did get a Christian
burial I mean he asked for one and you
would think that he had if he had done
all the [ __ ] that they said that he did
that the church would have said no I was
yet to get it again he was hanged and
then burned okay yeah but he was given a
Christian burial yeah and now I'm not
that's what I mean I think that that was
kind of not widely known until later on
like after you know as far as I know
this woman that wrote this book later on
and she translated a lot of the [ __ ]
from the time like out of Latin and Adam
French and stuff and she's like I think
they were trying to keep that a secret
that he had had a Christian burial he
had asked for one but as I said if he
had done what they said that he did then
I don't think the church would have
granted him that but they did that's
that's evident evidence to support the
idea that possibly the church knew that
the allegations were false that's kind
of what people are saying they're like
the fact that they actually did go ahead
and go yet just like give him a
Christian burial but like leave it on
the DL um that seems to suggest that
they knew that that that the charges
were either entirely false or were
wildly exaggerated well I'm going to
tell you right now man this whole shit's
fishy it does some very fishy and you
kill 600 kids you're gonna find bodies I
mean you know these [ __ ] bodies even
a hunk even 100 even 20 yeah even 15
where are these bodies exactly and what
they would have tortured a [ __ ]
all right and under torture he would
have given them in the exact location of
these bodies they would have dubbed
those bodies up and shown those little
kids skeletons to people and said he
did yeah but they didn't mean cuz that's
not what this was about I'm just always
really really wary of cases that are
based entirely on witness testimony
especially back in those days that's not
what this is about you got a young guy
with a [ __ ] ton of money he's popular
he's charismatic he's spending money
like a dumb animal
he's like a celebrity he's a man of the
people he's giving away free shows he's
buying all this [ __ ] he's a war hero
this [ __ ] a threat is what he
is yes he's a threat to the throne okay
he's very popular and he's got money and
he's investing in his own career his
family's complaining hey wait a minute
he's rocking the boat he's puttin our
family fortune at jeopardy please stop
this guy from spending all this money
but now the guy continues on he's a
young guy he's up at he you know if he's
an upstart everybody but everybody likes
him
dudes a threat yeah yet I mean he has
the money the charisma and the know-how
and the military experience to actually
buy his own army and actually overthrow
the government that's what I think this
is about yeah and like I said it should
be noted too that after Jill DeRay was
executed the Duke of Brittany got a
whole he got all the titles not only to
the the [ __ ] that chilled erase still
had left over because like I said he had
sold a lot of his properties off he also
got all the titles to the [ __ ] that Jill
Duran already sold off that was like in
other people's like he could have that
too
so all of his wealth went to people that
had a vested interest in prosecuting him
yeah so that really kind of gives me
pause and you know what I mean this was
a long time ago I'm not gonna say that
he didn't kill anybody or anything like
that but it seems a little sketchy
I don't think I hate anything dude those
killing those little kids it seems a
little sketch
that everybody that had something to do
with persecuting him stood to gain from
his death it's sketchy in a financial
way it's sketchy that they couldn't
produce not a single body of a child
yeah it's sketchy that they had not a
single complaint from a parent come
forward saying my son went with him and
he never came back
yeah it's fishy that's what I mean I
find this whole thing very fishy and
like I said it's kind of a case where I
mean obviously this happened you know in
1400 in the 1400s there's no way
anyone's going to know one way or the
other but to me it sounds very much like
a witch hunt I mean it sounds very much
like and when you talk about witch hunts
what comes to mind just like what
happened here in the United States you
know a lot of people that wrote about
what happened in certain towns during
which houses it's always the youngest
best looking guy who is the most popular
with the girls who's really good playing
fiddle it's always the really good
looking girl it's always the
[ __ ] that people are jealous of
people that they want to get rid of
right well and they usually want to get
rid of people because of jealousy too
they have money or they maybe they do
want to get rid of some old woman
because she's a [ __ ] you know I mean
that was the issue apparently you know
in Salem I think a lot of the problem
there was the women were they were
either weird or people didn't like them
or they have land that other people
wanted her they had been like and
there's you know they were a thorn in
someone's side there's money to be made
in a witch trial of all the [ __ ]
concessions that you can sell you know
what I mean there was ticket [ __ ]
involved you know yeah everybody would
come out to see the hangings yeah yeah I
mean again they were kind of you know if
you ask me this is money and political
power than shells to be young and
up-and-coming very popular guy that's
what I think happened here yeah and I
they can't you don't come at me with a
body your
using this guy maybe killing up to 600
children produce one skeleton yeah then
they didn't do that well and you know
like I said it's it's kind of a case
where if he was tried nowadays he would
never get him knighted and I were gonna
say it's a little bit different with
Bathory with Countess báthory they
evidently had invest there was some show
up to her twice to say yeah we found
girls oh yeah there was blood in their
cages and we found a dead girl here and
you know what I mean yeah this she was
up to some [ __ ] and then also there were
there were peasants down in the towns
saying that the girls were disappearing
yeah which was kind of the case and
Hilda raised thing where some of the
peasants were saying oh yeah I sent my
kid off to but it had it wasn't an
epidemic proportions but yeah but it
wasn't really to the same extent and I
don't think it was as clear-cut
yeah those kids could have been found
later after the trial living in another
town there's a lot of stuff that can
happen and like I said I feel like to
the trial transcripts that we have
nowadays I think a lot of that was left
out and I think some of it was
exaggerated after the fact to make him
more to make him sound like more of a
monster yeah so like I'm not sure how
seriously to take all of these
allegations and I know that Jill DeRay
is kind of like gone down in history as
you know one of the world's first serial
killers quote-unquote you know it being
based on you know Bluebeard being based
on him and stuff like that but I'm not
really sure like I said I'm not saying
that he never killed anyone ever I'm
just saying that it seems a little
strange that the whole trial was based
on torture evidence yeah and like the
testimony and I've seen some [ __ ] there
was no evidence it was just not really
there was no physical evidence and I
just not that I know of I I couldn't
find anything about physical evidence
and I asked her I said was there
physical evidence bodies no I don't
think so was there any eyewitness
testimony that came came forth that you
didn't have to torture somebody to tell
you that she had
No and then I know of NMR and as it were
there any complaints
did anybody complain and come forward
saying that my son or disappeared no not
really
they had to go out and find all that
[ __ ] so I'm I'm gonna say the way things
were in those times and the background
of this guy man I'm this just stinks too
high yeah I don't know I'm just I'm kind
of skeptical I've been I think maybe he
was kind of the subject of they wanted
his money essentially yeah they just
wanted him out of the way and they
wanted his stuff he was a threat to the
powers right so I think they just kind
of manufactured it and I have seen a
couple things cuz like I said I watched
a bunch of different documentaries about
this and a lot of different you know a
lot of sources I think the Encyclopedia
Brittanica still has it it's like you
know he's a serial killer you kill all
these people and stuff but you know
there is some controversy that exists
still about it which I find kind of
interesting but you know I've seen some
of the documentaries we're kind of like
well would anyone have really like made
up like all these crazy stories yeah at
these servants or stuff like that I'm
like oh yeah you've read the transcripts
from the Salem would you like the
[ __ ] bat [ __ ] stuff they came up with
kissing the yeah and a lot of it was
like came from was like biblical sources
or like you know other writings that
were like based on biblical sources I
mean that's some crazy [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
medieval European they were very
imaginative via medieval Europeans and
Renaissance era Europeans were not good
sources they were liars they lied a lot
yeah they've been proven best sheepies
if you [ __ ] threaten to torture
somebody yeah they do the deal you had
to lie yeah and put somebody in that
situation there we're gonna [ __ ] make
up all and like you said it's like
sometimes the more outrageous the story
is the more I really wish that people
would believe it because it's like who
would make up something yeah niccolò
machiavelli and [ __ ] cassock niccolò
machiavelli
and of course you know who's the other
guy I'm thinking of Friedrich Nietzsche
they'll tell you that if you're gonna
lie lie big yeah because the more
outrageous that lie is the more the
general population will for exactly that
reason because people strike while will
never make it right people can make up
all yeah yeah I'm a horror writer I make
up all kind of [ __ ] and then like it's
little kids cause I think people
underestimate other people's
imaginations you know what I mean you
can make up some crazy a [ __ ] and some
of the stuff that I read you know in the
Salem witch trials transcripts that is
some insane [ __ ] and I think it's like
on the level of this kind of thing so I
don't think it's completely outlandish
to say that this stuff was all made up
because that was the kind of [ __ ] that
they made up at this time period if you
go through every kind if you ever have
to go through a trial or have to go you
know I mean into the criminal justice
system unfortunately testimony plays a
big part in a conviction but they'll
tell you the jury could instructions
that testimony really isn't [ __ ] where
really what matters is physical evidence
well yeah because witnesses memories
right is notoriously inaccurate so if
you come in would come at me with a case
like this all he killed 400 kids and
blow about and without any physical
evidence not even a single body you're
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] yeah I'm kind of
leaning toward and then you talk about a
guy who's rich in the ruling class has
everything everything to gain from
taking this down show ya then a long
time ago we will never know we weren't
there but I'm saying just based on that
right there I'm gonna say [ __ ] no then
they made that [ __ ] up and honestly in
in the early 1990s there's still kind of
a thing in France because in France he's
still you know largely considered like
this monster but in 1992 I think it was
largely based on this book that this
woman wrote were
she kind of like retranslated all the
original like the all the contemporary
source material and she kind of came to
the conclusion was like she didn't think
he did anything like he was completely
innocent that he was just completely
railroaded because they wanted to get
rid of him so she kind of got together
this big like it was more it wasn't like
an official trial or anything but it was
kind of like a big media blitz about how
we're gonna exonerate Jill DeRay of all
of this stuff because he's been accused
of you know all these centuries he's
been like accused of being like some
monster he's like Bluebeard and he
really didn't do anything so she was
kind of like behind this push to like
get his name cleared I guess and what
they did in 1992 in France was they had
kind of like a media event that where
they had judges and lawyers they had all
kind of stuff it wasn't like I said an
official thing but they sort of looked
at all of the original evidence again
and then they exonerated him because
they said you know if this had come to
trial today there's no way that he would
have been convicted of anything because
it was just no you gotta produce it was
it was all witness it was all witness
testimony and like I said much of that
witness testimony stemmed from you know
people under under duress under torture
or threat of torture which you know
that's not worth it is notoriously
inaccurate yeah so I'm kind of leaning
toward maybe he didn't really do much of
anything
um I think like I said he probably did
kidnap and beat up that one dude but
that's it's not good but that's like a
pretty far cry from decapitating a
hundred children and [ __ ] their neck
holes another thing is is that if they
really believed this was true and
somebody said yeah we buried him out in
the moat or whatever they would have
gone out there to dig one of them up and
say see he's telling the truth here's
the kid's body that's what I know if the
servant said oh we threw them in the
moat are we through there was a suspect
you think somebody would go in at least
in some boat there was no attempt to go
verify that because they knew it I don't
think they wanted to bury it no you want
to verify they knew was [ __ ] yeah
cuz they said oh if we go out there guys
that anything the guys in the church and
[ __ ] to torture people to [ __ ] get
confessions out knew that that [ __ ]
didn't work because they knew that they
made those
confessions up and just said torture
them until they signed it
yeah they didn't but I kind of feel like
that's why the game of Christian burial
they knew it was [ __ ] but then
everybody got their cut and they [ __ ]
because my chance I mean Jill DeRay
whatever he did or didn't do he was
apparently a very pious Catholic so
there was that I don't think it's not
how I'm they have a head more state
about it once we just shut it down right
dad right yeah okay look at it man John
working he's done working that's nice I
never I never get done working I sleep
in back
alright so that'll do it for episode 144
about Jill DeRay uh let us know what you
think in the comments who you think he's
guilty not guilty at all really like I
said I I don't think so but you know if
you're like a medieval historian let me
know what you think about it cuz I just
gotta have this Co evidence yeah that's
what I'm saying that it's as far as I
know they didn't find anybody so [ __ ]
that all right so that'll do it for this
episode and remember if you've liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media if you would like to
financially support the show would be
much appreciated and go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button to esata to
a PayPal account that will if you want
to give a one-time donation that would
be much appreciated also and remember
our regular episodes come out every
Tuesday and we also have movie
retrospectives usually older movies that
comes out every Friday and we also have
moved matinee which is three new movies
in the theater that comes out every
Sunday so check them all out if you
haven't already and we will see you next
time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]